if some part of your politics is genetic
then the most important decision you
make in your child's political ideology
is who you mate with right because your
genes and their genes join together to
have children who
have particular kinds of political
biases that are influenced by
your genetic propensities
but how do you know
right how do you know even when you ask
people maybe they don't know maybe
they're lying to you how do you actually
know
in an automatic immediate way what
somebody else's ideology is
and for
certain reasons
we speculated that it had to do with
smell and specifically pheromones
this um
shows you why we thought this so this is
a
a slide where you basically can see the
extent to which certain uh chromosomes
are associated and when it's above you
know three times ten to the eighth where
you see it's significant those are
likely to occur not just by chance right
that it happens in a systematic way and
the ones that you'll see this is
political ideology by the way we're
looking at the genes that are associated
with political ideology this is one of
them and what you'll see is that these
are the things that are
the the chromosomes that are associated
with this are those that are related to
smell that are related to olfaction
and pheromonal strength so we had these
intuitions um based on these genome-wide
analyses that maybe smell had something
to do with
the way that people were able to
automatically determine
unconsciously this is not a conscious
process the political ideology of people
that they might get involved with so
we did a study where we looked at facial
and body um
both
sound we did we taped people's voices
saying hi how are you we manipulated
them so half of them were just neutral
hi how are you half of them were
seductive like hi how are you um and um
we
also took pictures of people and most
importantly we did a paradigm based on
the wet t-shirt test although we didn't
actually use t-shirts we had people
um
have
gauze pads under their underarms for day
and there's a particular protocol they
have to wash their hair they have to
wash their body they wear it for 24
hours they can exercise but there's
certain foods they can't eat they can't
be around candles and other things that
smell um specifically you can't sleep
with another person or an animal that
night you kind of can't believe people
will do this for 25 bucks but they do
um
and uh
then they come in you give it to you
know they give you the the pads the next
day and then what you do is you freeze
them and you slice them up and you do
various things and then you bring in
another group of people and you have
them smell them
and you ask those people well what does
it smell like to you is this a
trustworthy smell is this somebody that
you think is warm is it somebody you
think is competent is it somebody blah
blah so what's interesting about it is
there's absolutely no correlation on all
these things like is this person warm
are they competent are they trustworthy
there's no correlation we ask people can
you tell if this is a liberal or
conservative
can't tell at all but you ask them do
you like this smell are you attracted to
this smell do you want to sleep with
this smell and it completely predicts
whether or not that person's ideology
matches their own they can't tell you
consciously but the attraction is there
so we had 190 people we used various
pictures
uh we had these voice samples by the way
the voice stuff um
was interesting we didn't get any
findings by whether or not the voices
were seductive or neutral but what we
did get are asymmetries by conservatives
and liberals so liberals really don't
like the sound of conservative voices
and conservatives really don't like the
smell of liberals
and this is a this is the slide that
shows this um
the this is conservative smelling
conservatives liberals smelling liberals
the m f have to do with males and
females um
so and it's a little backwards right so
this one is male smelling females male
smelling males female smelling so the
people who like each other smell the
least are women like each other smells
the least this was a heterosexual sample
i should say
um
so you can see that there's there's
differences in it and there are
asymmetries
but these are all statistically
significant differences where you can
see that
these are related to
people's automatic you know unconscious
inference about
how these things work the study was very
interesting when i did it because the
first day i was we're really not sure it
was going to work and we opened up the
vial and i gave it to my lab manager and
she smelled it and she's like yeah it's
okay because we were kind of like is
this going to gross people out
and so she brought in her boyfriend and
said smell this
and he smelt it and he threw up
like i had to do this vegas thing on him
to stop him from throwing up and he's
like that is rancid and i smelled it and
i'm like it's not rancid she smelled it
she's like it's not rancid and i was
like this study is so gonna work
[Music]
you